boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and we
are still at the American
Anthropological Association Annual
Meeting and I am super excited now to be
sitting down dr. Diego V Hill thank you
for joining us on the show my pleasure
thank you really appreciate I'm really
excited to talk to you let's give a
background on Diego urban
anthropologists focus on Mexican
Americas professor emeritus of social
ecology at UC Irvine PhD in anthropology
from UCLA and various teaching and
administrative positions focus on ethno
history education cultural change ache
acculturation and adolescent and youth
issues especially street gangs and he's
a six-time author everything from street
smarts cool smart to from Indians to
Chicanos to gang Redux to a rainbow of
gangs personas meheecan us and barrio
gangs so I'm really excited to talk to
you because it's like you've been
analyzing something that is very
pressing that society needs to learn
about which is the way that we we behave
in and engage with with culture of youth
that is kind of splits when I was
learning about you you have analyzed the
way that that humans split due to social
and economic pressures into either gangs
or normal life yes that's great yeah I
have a theoretical framework that I
utilize to explain all the varying
facets of this split it's called
multiple marginality because I don't
just focus on one factor one force I
talk about the cumulative additive
nature of all the different forces that
affect youth and turn them to the
streets and then as part of that Street
socialization they develop a street
identity unfortunately that one of the
dominant street forces now are gangs and
what are the most prevalent social
pressures that guide youth into gangs
and
yeah let's go again the additive nature
yeah first of all they may be a
different ethnic group and racially
distance from the major population
that's how you get segregation to people
in different neighborhoods
that's one force and that's an important
one and then within their families they
may be struggling economically not able
to totally support their children and
all the different needs that they have
that's another force and then within the
family if the economic pressures and the
discrimination take their toll you might
not have a very intact family it may not
be organized according to the
middle-class families to have a decent
living that are more or less accepted in
society so you wind up with kids that
are the parents lacked parent skills or
our absent in terms of parenting so
that's another fad and then the other
factor again when schools are not able
to handle these students that are not
been raised with all the resources they
need and the guidance they lack from
parents and other adults they begin to
associate inter and hanging around with
other equally sort of uneducated and
sort of ignored students and by hanging
around with them they get solace and
support but they also learn more about
habits and then eventually the school is
strained families are enabled to really
guide their children those two forces
along with the neighborhood in the
racism segregation experience so you
wind up with kids interacting with law
enforcement in a very negative way one a
lot of force of the fuels they have to
sort of show early who's in charge and
this is the way you're behaving you guys
are behaving inappropriately but again
all those different factors and all
those different pressures all those
different gaps voids create
the need for an identity and since they
grow up in the streets more regularly
than you do at school in law enforcement
then they develop a street identity and
personality pursue their street oriented
and that's it
and from there who do they deal with who
are their peers other similarly
disaffected children yes you know
they're young teenagers maybe older
teenagers and sometimes you have a group
of them a kind of a young adult peer
group they're not the same ages 12 13 14
year-olds that are just getting in to
the street life but they've been around
19 20 years old they've been around a
while a lot more hardened and then they
sort of become the street counselors to
these youths oh man so the variety of
pressures from inside their family all
the way to once they are actually there
they have the the it's almost a benefit
of having a clique of people of almost
love it so that's the word they use the
love and they take care of their home
boys they watch their back and sometimes
the only person these kids on the
streets count on are similarly Street
socialize children that's how they form
groups and then the group's could become
more lethal and become gangs take for
example of Central America for the
longest time most of the 20th century
you always had street children in
Honduras and Nicaragua and Guatemala
they were poor they hung around together
but they didn't form gangs as we norm
here in Los Angeles or the United States
but once we started deporting street
gang were
to Central America this is after the
King riots of 1992 immigration
authorities and police had this bright
idea that they're gonna solve the game
problem here it's a hot potato
so they rounded up all the youngsters
who were in gangs that didn't have their
papers they weren't citizens they
deported him to those countries and they
hound around thousands of yeah yeah
hundreds for sure perhaps even thousands
and they went to their home country that
they had never known because they came
here as infants and young children
they've been America Americans more than
they've been Guatemalans so they go back
to this country but amount of Central
American countries ms-13 started like
that they sent them back there and they
socialized the kids that are street
children but not gang into what you
should he should be organized into into
the Mara Salvatrucha 13 or 18 Street or
some of the other gangs that are the
these deported children are from here in
Los Angeles so that's a good way of
teaching gang culture to kids that are
Street and poor oriented but not gangs
as we know and that's how that's how we
had ms-13 grow to be such a powerful and
instrumental Street group in the Western
Hemisphere
not just Los Angeles or prequel Union
area that's one example when you use the
policy just misguided and not really a
thoughtful not obviously not by based on
social science and then they send them
there thinking that's gonna solve the
problem here now hot potato has been set
someplace else
yeah Wow and then what about the the
solutions to the hot potato that you've
been understanding you you went and you
looked at gaining chuck injunctions
right yeah teach us about that well the
gang injunction along was a step act
Street terrorism enforcement policy
these two laws were put into place in
the late 1980
when gang problems with at the highest
level and gang injunction in particular
was aimed at a neighborhood that had a
very violent in the problematic gang
there was a nuisance to the rest of the
neighborhood and the community as this
neighborhood was being gentrified well
that came later okay these neighborhoods
then were ice where identified as gang
problem neighborhoods so the law
enforcement police and District Attorney
had this law the gang injunction they
take a man named different gang members
and they said they couldn't hang around
with each other they couldn't dress a
certain way a lot of different
infringement on the civil rights this is
a way of combating gangs but what
happened is that they didn't just
identify the violent most problematic
gangs they identified areas that were
being chips rights and the first of the
example and the police patrolled those
areas they were patrol of and then they
Datak gang injunction would maybe make
it easier to keep watch over these guys
because I had their name and they told
him what who they could hang around with
how they could dress anywhere they could
be I mean the cheese and the plus if
they the setback was a law that if he
committed an infraction they were thrown
in jail for a longer period of time and
given a heavier penalty for those that
loved gang injunction in the case that I
was at expert witness was in orange
Vario cypress in Orange County right
next to Chapman University Chapman was
growing at the University they needed a
land and right next door was an old
neighborhood that it once been the
migrant workers of the 1920s in fact
their neighborhoods right across the
street from the packing plants they're
still there you know wooden buildings
from nineteen twenties and so Chapman
needed that land for their expansion
they got a whole a law enforcement they
got a hold of this security
we need that land so urban renewal get
rid of Mexicans or in this case the gang
injunction this get rid of this
the gang wasn't even that lethal didn't
have that many infractions but we went
to court and we proved to the judge that
the district attorney named too many
gang members they weren't gang members
just kids there were in the neighborhood
and they were cousins or friends of one
of the gang members so they had it such
a a large net and they picked really
identified so many kids so in quarter we
proved to the judge that this was not
correct not a way to go about cleaning
up a gang problem in neighborhood and
the judge agreed was the jury agreed
with whatever case we presented and they
got rid of it in that case was taken to
a higher authority court and and they
agreed with the earlier judge there was
not it was unconstitutional to do that
now nah-nah enforcement has pulled back
from that law alley I was also part of a
case because I was a big net right right
we're saying well you pick up anybody
any kid the neighborhood it's
automatically labeled a gang member when
in fact they're you know they in the
plus the fact that they identified it as
a very violent gang in neighborhood and
it was a nuisance to the other residents
there when in fact there were all kinds
of neighborhoods they were worse in
violence and more reduces and those were
ignored because they were not part of
gentrification so that's the way of
cleaning up and using a law poorly and
that now they can use the law they're
eliminating the use of that policy as a
solution to gangs fortunately since the
9th late 1990s there's been an effort to
do something other than punishment
because there's three things you can do
with gangs you caprera
for joining you could
suppressive that's what you have law
enforcement or you could intervene so
prevention intervention is a lot cheaper
not better a lot earlier so school
freshen this is suppression that's when
you have gang injunctions yeah that's
not that that has not worked and in fact
the motive for using it is not even what
I was intended for it was something else
so they CLU and that I worked closely
with were successful of getting these
things cut back and on the verge of
being eliminated and it seems as though
the education the prevention step in the
very youth is the best well of course
yeah the younger the better headstart
and every year headstart has difficulty
getting fully funded head strategies
that would be one prevention effort that
would save us a lot of money a lot of
headaches get these kids young begin to
teach them how to be a good student the
other read my wife is a board member and
there was school what are your school
district and their main objective is get
two kids to read by third grade and you
get her to do that that opens all kinds
of ystös for them it helps the rectum
and a more conventional pro-social way
and the schools make efforts to have
programs to integrate students that come
from
economically different backgrounds and
also been treated the racists barriers
and other kinds of four methods of
integrating them into society and then
also out of out of your other books that
you've authored what have been some of
the big highlights for you that you
would want to share well this is a my
first book is my favorite I'm working on
it right
was a barrio gangs no I'm talking about
earlier
what's earlier than that Familia said
Chicanos oh it's a history of 500 years
going back to the pre-columbian nastic
time to the president hmm Chicano move
in time and the 500 years of contact
conflict had change and developments
where you have the submergence of
operation and the emergence of a
superior elite population we're trying
to make it a mixed reality game that got
virtual reality and I'm very excited
about that because there's a lot of
action a lot of Wars a lot of upheavals
a lot of disagreements over race and
culture and religion that can be the
source of the conflict and that's kids
learning about having a good time
shooting them up but why and how and
where some of the information that's
more academically based there would be
of use for kids to get that information
and who was being submerged and who was
being we're talking about the Indians of
the Western Hemisphere yeah yeah in the
Africans that were brought in against
their wishes the better judgement of
slaves so the the population that was
here and the population was brought in
and what happened to these two
populations and I we have a story line
were developed we have about 10 tribes
including some of the maroon black
groups who started like the Seminoles
the Seminoles were a black Indian group
that merged together and there are other
spots that Veracruz Eastern Mexico and
in Acapulco in western Mexico where
there was a large African population
then merged with a populates the Indian
population so we're talking about
natives of the Western Hemisphere
natives of the Western Hemisphere for
500 years I have a new year some
emergence emergence under the Spanish
yeah
and then the anglo-american angle well
actually needs to be fair about it
Spanish the Mexicans the Anglo and now
well we get everyday news headlights
about the caravan and about immigration
and about how we have a lot of criminals
and rapists greatness here from the
immigrant population that's helped us
build up the industries that helps in
the wars I have totally uncles that were
in World War one I had a brother in
World War two join the day after Pearl
Harbor we're very proud of our
achievements in being good Americans
yeah like Jews we just want to be
treated fairly and equitably yes yes so
for many astute Kano's is my favorite
book right now you live in the gang
books that are very good and useful and
I'm very proud of those books too and
mostly growing up in downtown Los
Angeles on the streets myself I learned
what that life is all about never really
got into serious trouble
what's through sports I was able to go
to colleges and from there I started
getting turned on to different academic
subjects so Diego - two quick points
here that I want to ask you about
well first one is what have been some of
your favorite moments from teaching kids
well a favorite moment is when kids you
could see the light bulb turn on yeah
for the ideas that I might be sharing
giving them an inside like for instance
one of the facts that it's surprising to
so many students including a lot of
Chicano mexican-american students there
was a war between the United States in
Mexico in 1846 and 48 it's called the
mexican-american war the United States
took over one-third of Mexican territory
all those states that have funny names
California
New Mexico Nevada are Indian tribes or
Spanish named for the state based on
historical circumstances so they say San
Diego City where all those names tell us
that people were here before yeah and
people that were decent folks families
were important and there was efforts to
keep peace and quiet and all that stuff
but was a war the United States wrote a
treaty with Mexico the trivia Waterloo
mezzago
and then Trinity we're gonna preserve
the ownership of land the ladies had
land that they owned okay they were
gonna preserve the culture in their
language and that was ignored just
complete Boulder pulled over so that's
when I like lecture about the Mexican
work students look at me like like
dumbfounded yeah there's a war you mean
when we didn't immigrate here well the
line that see people use it but we
didn't cross the border the border
crossed us damn I have family that was
born in New Mexico before the war yeah
my grandfather was born in 1842 in New
Mexico okay so anyway and I'm real proud
of being an American
and in fact Mexicans Korat collaborated
with the United States and in helping
their taking it over the Southwest you
study some of the events the Alamo had
all kinds of mixes yeah and it was just
Angliss so it's not that we were like
trying to kowtow to the dominant racial
group to see if we go over the nation or
the territory it's like this there's
certain political if social principles
the United States abides by and we like
those principles we just want to apply
it equally in regularly over a period of
time yes
exactly I can't believe it that you just
said that the porter didn't you didn't
cross the board the border was put by us
yeah yeah I was pushed there across then
plus right after the war Mexican labor
was needed millions of Mexicans came to
work the farms the cattle ranches the
mines they built up the southwest they
were contributors major caster reader
says and now little are they still are
may jelly and then the work of original
with person Wayne we just did little
respect
I've had many lightbulbs go off while
we've been talking and so I am happy
that you picked that as something that
you love with teaching now last thought
what are your thoughts about the current
state of humanity and where we're
heading I'm very disappointed the older
I get the more disappointment and for
instance the other day we celebrated its
100-year anniversary the world war one
that was a major conflict yes I mean
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
people died I think it was a battle of
our own my true uncle's where the
Argonne in that force area and our
president didn't even go to the
ceremonies other people Arnie are
completely oblivious to that major
conflict it should be taught in schools
the importance of that kind of ethnic
cleansing you know so many people killed
this learn from those lessons yes and
then we repeat war or war too then we
have all these smaller versions of the
wars and I'm disappointed that well the
United Nations he was given a little bit
of power at the beginning and then more
and more people just ignored that and
don't understand that the world is too
small now it's got to be made peaceful
you got to get rid of this this is
religious and economic and other complex
in order to have more peace and
tranquility and raise our children in a
easy kind of way or they can enjoy life
and get into art into intellectual
pursuits scientific pursuits and that is
what you know we have were in
Afghanistan or in Iraq
we're rattling swords with North Korea
you know it's just like goes on and on
and and unfortunately the population
seems to enjoy the fact that we are the
big cheese's in the kick and the man you
know what I mean that's that's not
conducive to making a peaceful quiet and
just internally development or when we
get externally involved help other
people develop you know and along the
same lines that we want to expand on
peace quality for our children in our
future we need to learn from the past
mistakes that have been made throughout
civilization I have a greater harmony a
greater stewardship and pass that to
children and have us thrive as a planet
right Diego I'm I have said I've had so
many light bulbs go off and I really
appreciate you sitting down with us and
I thank you for inviting me thank you
thank you for joining us I'm glad we met
last night me too Diego me too and thank
you everyone for tuning and we greatly
appreciate it give us your thoughts in
the comments below we'd love to hear
from you also check out Diego's links
below and check out triple A's links as
well please and go and build the future
go and manifest your destiny into the
world everyone thanks for tuning in much
love this